the American withdrawal is getting more
bad reviews around the world countries
on six continents of questioning
president Trump's decision the United
States joins the only two countries that
did not sign the agreement to cut
greenhouse gas emissions they are Syria
and Nicaragua even North Korea has
ratified the Accord then Tracy is in
Beijing with reaction from China which
the president strongly criticized in his
statement then good morning good morning
so all along China had said that
regardless of what the United States did
it was going to honor its commitment to
the Paris climate Accord so you have
leaders all over the world expressing
their dismay but here in China they see
an opportunity to become a global leader
in climate change
China is the biggest polluter on the
planet but now it's state-owned tabloid
is calling the US withdrawal reckless
and said America's selfishness and
irresponsibility would hurt its global
standing reaction from around the world
was swift want makan this morning German
Chancellor Angela Merkel called it
extremely regrettable Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau called it
disheartening and the Vatican went
further saying mr. Trump's decision was
a disaster for everyone
Paris bathed its city hall in green
lights and French President Emmanuel
macron made a forceful speech in English
it is an actual mistake both for the US
and for all planets after meeting with
President Trump last week in Europe
McCrone used the president's own words
against him we all share the same
responsibility make our planet great
again Germany France and Italy issued a
rare joint statement calling the Paris
Accord irreversible and stating it
cannot be renegotiated that was a blunt
rejection of president Trump's assertion
that he will eventually negotiate a
better deal on climate the president is
fundamentally shifting alliances around
the world the Chinese premier visited
Germany and Brussels this week to forge
a closer relationship with Europe China
plans to spend more than 360 billion
dollars on renewable energy by 2020
which it says will create at least 13
million new jobs
to give you a sense of just how much has
changed the president of the European
Commission said that he will likely be
working more closely with China now than
the United States and in rather scathing
remarks he says that when President
Trump was in Europe last week they tried
to explain the Paris Accord to him and
what they called simple terms and that
it appeared the president did not
understand Norah
alright Ben thank you